la méditerranée est une bouche gers et
dont la lèvre supérieure
s'expriment en latin et la lèvre
inférieure en arabe et quand elle tente
de déglutir quand les lèvres se
rapproche et bien là mal ça pique elle
souffre parce que il y a toutes ces
frontières tous ces barbelés tout ses
guérites tous et checkpoint autour de la
méditerranée qui l'empêchent de
s'exprimer et en 2011 moi j'étais à
marseille il ya eu les printemps arabes
et là on a senti qu'il y avait des
individus libres qui reprenait la parole
qui refusait de se laisser
prendre dans ce dans ces sacs de
barbelés qui reprenait le droit
d'exister et de dire ce qu'ils avaient
envie de dire
et je me suis dit à ce moment là que ce
qu'il fallait faire c'était aller les
écouter tout simplement c'est à dire non
plus considérer la méditerranée comme
cet ensemble d'états nations qui ne se
parlent pas les uns avec les autres mais
comme
une communauté d'habitants qui ne se
connaissent pas pas très bien et d'aller
les écouter
et de créer une grande bibliothèque une
base de données commune libre de droit
une bibliothèque d'histoire vraie
d'habitants des habitants de la
méditerranée dans toutes les langues de
la méditerranée j'ai proposé ça à
marseille 2013 qui était capitale de la
culture à l'époque et donc à partir de
décembre 2011 je suis parti faire mon
petit tour au micro et j'ai commencé par
barcelone je savais pas trop comment
faire au début j'allais voir les gens un
peu sur les bancs et petit à petit on
s'est mis en place un certain nombre de
possibilités de collecte on peut
collecter des histoires vraies en tête à
tête avec quelqu'un qu'on a rencontrés
on peut faire ça ici ensemble vous allez
tous venir et raconter une histoire
vraie on peut faire des veillées aux
chandelles on peut faire des tables et
on peut faire il ya trente six manières
de collecter et de la même manière des
36 manière de restituer les histoires et
tous les harkis sont évidemment
capables de raconter ses histoires donc
j'ai commencé comme ça c'était en
espagne ensuite j'étais au maroc en
janvier 2012 puis en algérie et là le
projet partie parce qu'il ya eu
énormément d'histoires algériennes qui
sont arrivés à la fois sous forme de
texte sur le site internet qu'il est
rassemblé et puis j'ai rencontré plein
de gens
voilà ça vraiment ça vraiment démarré en
février 2012 cette collecte ensuite
j'étais en tunisie et là aussi ça a été
très très belle rencontre
ensuite j'ai pas pu aller en libye avec
ce qui se passait et je suis allée en
egypte je suis arrivé au liban je suis
arrivé au liban j'ai continué à
collecter j'étais beaucoup à beyrouth et
à un moment j'étais invité à rahmane a
fait une petite ville
sur les hauteurs du mont liban à
majorité chrétienne à environ trois
quarts d'heure de beyrouth et là je suis
arrivé et les gens m'attendaient on
était tous dans la bibliothèque c'était
comme une veillée aux chandelles mais au
milieu des livres et là on a tous pris
la parole moi j'ai raconté une histoire
mais les gens les plus vieux les plus
jeunes en français en arabe se sont
raconté ils ont choisi c'est ce que je
demandais à chaque fois aux jambes parmi
le reste le récit de leur vie de zéro a
maintenant quelle serait cette histoire
que vous avez envie de partager avec le
reste du monde quelle serait cette
anecdote marquante qui vous tient à
coeur qui vous est cher que ce que vous
avez envie de mettre en commun dans une
grande bibliothèque
et la voilà il j'ai eu plein d'histoire
puis on s'est retrouvés pour boire un
coup à la fin il ya 5000 à fakhoury qui
était la directrice de la bibliothèque
qui me dit il ya une histoire que je
vais pas raconter ça se passe en
c'est la première année
de la guerre civile
au liban et c'est aussi l'année où
l'armée syrienne est venu occuper le
libre et ils ont installé en particulier
à rahmane les canons pour bombarder
beyrouth et il attendait les ripostes
quand samira et son mari ont vu ça ils
ont décidé de mettre les enfants en
sécurité dans la plaine de la bekaa côté
des harley et de rester à amman a pour
s'occuper des maisons de famille pour
pas qu'elles soient pillés dont il y
avait trois maisons et eux ils sont
restés il y avait la grand mère dans une
des autres maisons et une des maisons a
été réquisitionné par les officiers
syriens dont qui habitait dans une de
leurs maisons ils étaient voisins et au
printemps comme tous les ans samira et
son mari se disputent et ils se
disputent toujours pour la même raison
à cause des peupliers
ils ont quatre peupliers qui sont à côté
du jardin et je suis pas si vous voyez
mais les peupliers ça fait des petites
boules de coton ça fait des petites des
bourgeons puis après ça ça fait ces
boules là qui salissent tous les jardins
et à chaque fois c'est pareil au
printemps le mari de samira lui dit
c'est la dernière année à l'asse
peupliers là je vais m'en débarrasser je
vais les coupes et les peupliers et
samira qui vise mais tu peux pas faire
ça il faut qu'on vive avec les arbres
ils nous font de l'ombre l'été et un
moment donné il ya l'officier syrien qui
vient à passer et qui entend c'est c'est
la première fois qu'il les entend se
disputer et dit mais qu'est ce qu'il ya
madame fakoly il ya un problème elle est
tellement énervé après son mari et puis
c'est aussi peut-être la tension qui est
lié à l'occupation à la guerre
elle regarde les fichiers comme ça dit
c'est mon mari il va me divorcé il veut
me divorcé ça y est l'officier syrien il
est là il entend ça et c'est parce qu'il
avait ça se trouve il est ému peut-être
que ça fait des mois qu'il n'a pas vu sa
femme lui aussi
et il est là il dit mais
pourquoi il peut pas faire ça il est
vrai il peut pas prendre cette décision
il faut qu'il réfléchisse plus longtemps
le mariage c'est sacré il peut pas vous
divorcez comme saddam fakoly vous êtes
une femme très bien et c'est samir et
lui dit ils veulent divorcer et monsieur
l'officier syrien je vais vous dire
pourquoi
moi je veux rien savoir s'écouter cessez
vos histoires personnelles c'est vrai
c'est votre vie privée je ne veux rien
savoir si si si je veux vous dire
pourquoi vous voyez ces peupliers
monsieur l'officier syrien vous voyez
ces cas peupliers et ben ils font des
petites boules de coton comme ça des
petites boules ça tombe ça salit son
jardin il vous coupez les peupliers moi
je veux pas qu'ils coupent les peupliers
alors il va me divorce est
officiel syrien la regarde comme ça
c'est ça votre problème madame fakoly
ses salles à votre problème
est là
il se retourne comme ça et il appelle
ses soldats il se retourne il appelle
ses soldats il les appelle comme des
animaux et ayane venait là mais soldats
rassemblés vous autour du jardin de
madame fakhoury
tous les soldats se rassemble
l'officier dit vous voyez ces quatre
peupliers soldats oui on voit les quatre
peupliers et bien mes soldats
vous allez me cueillir tous les
bourgeons des peupliers et là ça m'ira
me dit j'ai vu l'armée syrienne
monter trois par trois dans mes
peupliers je voulais faire une photo
j'ai pas osé et cueillir délicatement
les bourgeons de ces peupliers puis
descendre et les mettre dans des sacs
je me suis dit quand même quand même cet
officier syrien il a eu du coeur il a eu
peur pour mon couple
elle me dit ça et voilà on finit la
soirée et puis je continue mon
périple je vais ensuite ans en turquie
beaucoup à izmir
en grèce à athènes
en sicile j'ai fait que la sicile en
italie je finis par israël où j'ai passé
pas mal de temps dans à tel-aviv dans
les kibboutz à
haifa nazareth et puis en palestine où
j'ai commencé par hébron qui a été un
vrai choc puis ramallah puis naplouse
bethléem et ensuite j'ai passé du temps
à écrire à partir de toutes ces
histoires qui avait été collecté
sous deux formes différentes
les histoires les rendre les re raconter
aux gens sous la forme d'un livre la
lune dans le puits qui le recueille
histoire vraie où je donne l'exemple
c'est ce que j'aimerais qu'on essaye de
faire ensemble
à chaque fois qu'on nous raconte une
histoire vraie je sais pas si ça vous la
fais quand je vous ai raconté cette
histoire des peupliers en fleurs mais on
finit aussi par penser soi-même en
miroir à nos propres histoires vraies et
donc dans ce livre la lune dans le puits
je raconte aussi moi mes propres
histoires vraies du de la naissance
jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai fait ça j'ai fait des créations
sonores pour arte radio et puis il ya
quelques mois avec un groupe de gens qui
est de différentes compétences on a créé
une association qui s'appelle histoire
vraie de la méditerranée et
j'ai initié ça pour l'instant ya 1500
histoire vraie qui sont dans cette
bibliothèque dans cette base de données
est l'idée c'est qu'on en ait des
milliers et des milliers et d'avancé et
donc on va envoyer aux quatre coins de
la méditerranée
des auteurs des artistes de tous types
des chercheurs et pour qu'ils aillent au
plus près donc chez l'habitant en
résidence écouter les gens puisque c'est
vraiment ça qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
c'est repartir de l'individu
je trouve que la méditerranée est une
bonne échelle
à partir du moment où on la considère
pas au niveau de ses états nations on la
considère en deçà ou au delà de ses
frontières
et c'est au niveau de l'individu qui me
semble qu'on peut reconstruire quelque
chose c'est pour ça qu'il me semble très
important de faire ce geste d'aller à
l'écouté des gens quels qu'ils soient
de mettre cette parole ces récits ces
histoires vraies en commun et ensuite
peut-être qu'on pourra enfin faire la
méditerranée